-♪ Mad Lib Theater ♪
♪ Uh-huh, yeah ♪
-This is how it works.
I'm going to ask you for
some silly words -- nouns,
verbs, adjectives, et cetera.
As we do that, they'll be
written on cue cards.
-Okay.
-And then we're going to act out
a very dramatic...
-Yes.
...Mad Lib scene.
-Don't -- this is serious.
-Oh, I know.
-Take it seriously.
Seriously, don't smile.
-Be serious.
-Yeah, be serious for once.
-Don't laugh.
-Hey, hey, hey.
[ Light laughter ]
-I mean, you have to know how...
-This is really hard.
-...hard my life is.
-It's so hard.
-All right.
-It's hard.
-Ready?
-Okay.
-Silly word.
-Um, uh...[ Laughs ]
spectacularlicious?
-Wow.
My cue card guy just fainted.
[ Laughter ]
Spectacularicious.
[ Laughs ]
I'll leave that up my cue card.
He's like, [ gasping ]
Name you'd give a cat?
-Um, Fluffy Girl.
[ Light laughter ]
I'm not a cat person.
-A type of nut.
-Oh, coconut.
[ Laughter ]
-Coconut.
Adjective.
-Um, uh...fuzzy.
Did I say that?
No, I said fluffy.
-No, you said fluffy.
-Different.
-It's all good.
-Yeah.
-What would you shout if you saw
a monster under your bed?
-Not today, Satan!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-Not today, Satan.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Letter of the Alphabet.
-Um...Q.
-Q.
Something you hate doing.
-Um, going to the dentist.
-Really? I like it.
-Ugh.
I like the after, but the
during -- very uncomfortable.
-Really?
-Yeah, I don't like it.
-Do you gas it?
-No.
Is that the secret?
-I don't know.
People are afraid
of dentists, they --
-I'm afraid of gassing.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm a lightweight.
-I don't know if it's called
gassing or if they do this.
But I know that --
I think it just makes you laugh.
Quest, you're always going
to the dentist.
Do you have gas?
-Do you take the gas?
-Questlove!
Questlove, do you have gas?
[ Laughter ]
-Are you gassy?
Are you gassy?
-Yes, he's very gassy.
Yeah, okay.
-Sure.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
-No.
-Give me a number.
Give me a number.
-Um...seven billion.
[ Laughter ]
-Adjective.
Another adjective.
-Okay. Um...
-You already said
fuzzy and fluffy.
-...smelly.
[ Laughter ]
-Plural animal.
-Uh, um...frogs.
-Old TV show.
-"Good Times."
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers ]
-Yes, yes.
-Body part.
-Um...belly button.
[ Laughter ]
-Verb ending in "ing."
-Oh, um...I'm thinking about
construction -- screwing.
[ Laughter ]
-Exclamation.
-Um, "Sweet Jesus!"
[ Laughter ]
-Amount of time,
like two minutes or 20 hours.
-Um...19 years.
-19 years.
Type of profession.
-Um, profession...
lady of the night.
[ Laughter ]
-This is fantastic.
A lady of the night.
How classy.
-It's the oldest profession.
-A noun.
-A noun, um...Range Rover.
[ Laughter ]
-Fantastic.
Celebrity name.
-Oh, um...Lady Gaga.
-Yeah, Lady Gaga.
Name of a famous athlete.
-Um, I'm scared
to say my husband
so I'll say um, uh,
Michael Jordan.
-Michael Jordan.
Plural noun.
We're almost done.
-Um, lily pads.
[ Laughter ]
-The frog theme.
-I'm having a frog day.
-Yeah, you're
having a frog moment.
Restaurant chain.
-Um, Olive Garden.
-Absolutely, man.
[ Cheers ]
When you're here
you're family, dude.
[ Laughter ]
We filled out
the words for our scene.
Are you ready to perform?
-Yes.
Are you ready?
-Very dramatic.
-Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I'm glad you were able
to make it to this
parent-teacher meeting,
Mr. Spectacularicious.
[ Laughter ]
Please have a seat.
-Oh, yes.
-You're supposed to wait
till I ask you to sit.
-Thank you, I -- yeah.
Good to see you again,
Ms. Fluffy Girl.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I want to talk to you about
your son, little Coconut.
[ Laughter ]
I've been a teacher for
many years and I've never seen
such a fuzzy child.
[ Laughter ]
-Not today, Satan!
Uh-uh, uh-uh!
[ Cheers ]
Not today, Satan!
-I -- no, I --
-Satan, not today, Satan!
Hey! [ Stomps floor ]
Not today, Satan!
-I am as surprised as you.
Your son is getting
a Q in math...
[ Laughter ]
...and a D in going
to the dentist.
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
-And for show and tell,
he brought in seven billion
smelly frogs.
[ Laughter ]
It was very smelly.
-I will --
-It was terrible.
-I will admit that his mother
and I started letting him stay
up late to watch "Good Times."
-Oh, well that explains it.
-How is little Coconut's
class participation?
-Well, you know,
he constantly calls out
even though I tell him
if he has a question,
he has to raise
his belly button.
-He has -- He has an outie.
He has an outie.
-He does.
He's got to raise it up.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Got to lift it up.
-Lift it up, yeah.
-He's gotta be proud.
-Not today, Satan!
Not today, Satan!
-Got to say,
"I have something to say."
Yeah, and today during
social studies, I found him
in the back
of the classroom, screwing.
[ Laughter ]
-Sweet Jesus!
Sweet Jesus!
Not today, Satan!
Oh, not today.
-I want to say one more thing.
-[ Laughs ]
You don't have
to raise your hand.
Is there anything
you suggest that I do
to help my son improve?
-Yes, of course.
That's why you're here.
I want you to read with him
at least 19 years every night.
[ Laughter ]
I actually just
bought him the book,
"Harry Potter and
The Ladies of the Night."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a very good one.
-It was a good --
That's a very good one.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's a very popular book here
at Lady Gaga Elementary School.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
So anyways, I also suggest
you sit down and make sure...
-Anyways.
-...that he does his homework.
-Oh.
-Because last time, he just said
that Michael Jordan ate it.
-Oh, that's a classic excuse.
I understand.
-But listen, he's very well
liked in class, very well liked.
And he often leads the other
students in singing his favorite
song, "The Lily Pads
on the Bus."
-Oh, I love that song.
Do you want to sing it together?
[ Laughter ]
-Of course.
-♪ The Lily pads on the bus
go round and round ♪
♪ Round and round ♪
♪ The Lily pads on the bus
go round and round ♪
♪ all through
the Olive garden ♪
And, scene!
That's how you do
it right there.
Kerry Washington.
You are the greatest.
-I love you.
-We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show" everybody.
Come on back.
[ Band plays ]